foreign
[Music]
I'm a comedian a producer entrepreneur I
write stuff and then I tell stories and
hopefully people can find them funny
so are you communion that's very unusual
unused when you first oh they still
don't know they don't get it I was born
here and grew up in America and Ireland
and so it was very very Irish and then I
moved here people didn't understand what
I was saying so I'm from gizabera over
there with you
to here can you pass the salt please
[Laughter]
you can't say things so we're here now
that do you need to get anything from
here what do you usually get from the
sugar
I'm waiting for a genie
[Music]
yeah
stereotypes never work be a billionaire
where's my I thought you are a
billionaire unfortunately not no
I only have one Rolls-Royce this is see
this is how great Healthcare is on Qatar
that even Falcons have their own
Hospital
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there hasn't been a World Cup
in a place the size of a city
you know how
um
what was the funniest pronunciation
you've heard quater
I swear to God equator Americans
cut it cutter cutter
he's going over it's a good time yeah
other stereotypes um that we all have
camels
I have never owned a camel I've eaten a
few but I've never owned a camel nor
have I ever raced a camel
thank you so much
[Applause]